[Music]
Coenen here welcome again in clueless
gamer today we're looking at the game
injustice gods among us here to tell us
more about the game my assistant nerd
Aaron Blair Aaron hello it's good to see
you actually before we get going
this comic book they released kind of
tells the prequel of the story that
we're gonna see so let me get this
straight you have to read a comic book
before you play the video game we've
entered a new level of nerd it's pretty
hot and heavy is that Lois Lane
yeah that's Lois Lane it's Superman Lois
Lane Superman a lot of nudity and
they're making out he gets her pregnant
actually whoa yeah that's the that's the
kind of the story gets her super
pregnant
alright hey I'm ready to fight first you
got to pick your character so on the
Left we have all the heroes yeah on the
right we have all the villains yes your
typical ones here we got Superman talked
me out of Superman
your man's the best there's no hero you
can come up with well
okay well what about there's Aquaman
he's got a big even fish are embarrassed
when they see Aquaman they put their
flippers up and they know who's stupid
the archer one who's that Oh Green Arrow
yeah here comes Superman how do we stop
him I've got a bow with an arrow
here's the cool thing we actually are
premiering General Zod this is a big
scoop for you kids get the cheese out of
your eyes cuz General Zod is in town you
can download this in July but quiet I'm
downloading General Zod alright let's
play I'm ready to fight I'll be Batman
alright he's a class so forth I'll play
Wonder Woman you could fight me here
comes Batman ineffectually taking a
shuttle from Boston to Detroit be
landing in about 40 minutes
she's a whip
it's very dominatrix see there we go oh
yeah now I'm just leaping I'm Batman was
in circus away I don't know what just
happened we just have sex quick but she
seems happy
Wonder Woman wins you're no match for an
Amazon that's humiliating
you know what Batman is gonna have a
hard time performing sexually I want to
be Lex Luthor in his metal suit okay
this will be two Superman enemies
fighting each other so we'll fight in
Superman's place the fortress of
solitude we're not just gonna play in
the fortress of solitude rate of play in
Superman's Zoo
he has a zoo yeah where he keeps all of
his alien creatures from all the plants
he's visited why does he do that that
seems creepy to take animals away from
their natural habitat Michael Jackson
did it you're right baby there must I
remind you of my superiority knowing
button-mashing like crazy
it's basically retyping life
[Applause]
take fighting turns into real fighting
the general zod is that bad girl yeah
I'm gonna be bad girl today
this planet will be by that guy just
flew through space and she's using a
rope to get around
okay General Zod is good man smash it
through the moon I think you're ahead in
points if you just threw me through the
moon I've done is be sarcastic whoa he
became hope future that's how you become
focus not there's no one claim any more
you fight back girl and if you win it's
right out to the don't touch yourself
lay has been dominating so we're gonna
even things up a little bit first I'd
like you to pick what I think would be a
lame character like Aquaman and I am
going to be a character that I
co-created with the genius Bruce Timm
the flaming see let me see
love flaming see look
[Applause]
I manage man's bit I'm just gonna kick
your ass are you gonna kick my ass I
think not here put this on let's put
this blindfold on and its feminine too
to even humiliate you more put it on now
we go now you go celebrate with the only
friends you have the fish you're fired
are you going you have nowhere to go
okay we've been playing injustice gods
among us I like this game I thought it
had great visuals I'm gonna give this
thing a grade if slapping play is a low
score and if punching him is a high
score and pushing you is sort of a
medium score I would give this game
protect will be plus
[Applause]
[Music]